hi everyone welcome is the Michael on
working thank you all for coming welcome
to everybody I'm Stephen pity professor
of history in American Studies and
director of the ethnicity race and
migration program and master of Ezra
Stiles college I want to issue a special
welcome to vice president Wendell armor
and our other distinguished guests
welcome to our home home is an important
subject and concern that animates much
of Richard Blancos work describing a
life of movement he has said it himself
that he was quote made in Cuba assembled
in Spain and imported to the United
States Richard grew up in Miami he
studied and worked as a civil engineer
he's lived in Brazil in Guatemala he's
authored three books of poetry he's read
and taught widely including here in our
state as a faculty member at central
connecticut state university and as you
all know he was recently named the fifth
inaugural poet in the history of the
united states unity and disunity
nostalgia and exile the particulars of
working-class Miami the household the
relationship between Spanish and English
these issues and others come forward in
much of his work but he engages to well
beyond the confines of familiar terrain
he has said that the first poem he ever
wrote in a graduate poetry course at
Florida International University was on
the broad topic what is America he's
remarked that quote I am a writer who
happens to be Cuban but I reserve the
right to write about anything I want not
just my cultural identity aesthetically
and politically I don't exclusively
align myself with any one particular
group Latino Cuban gay or white but I
embrace them all good writing is good
writing
I like what I like well audiences what I
think I still live audiences reviewers
award committees and leading elected
officials also like what they like and
they certainly admired Richard Blanco
Richard's writings have been celebrated
in the awarding of major fellowships a
major book prize and the inclusion of
poems in major anthologies his widely
heralded poem one today delivered at the
inauguration on January 8 2013 of course
brought him to the attention of new
audiences his publications have received
new acclaim in recent weeks as has the
fact that Richard was the youngest
inaugural poet in US history the first
immigrant the first Latino and the first
openly gay writer to receive that honor
so it's a real privilege to have Richard
Blanco here and Ezra Stiles and at Yale
University today please help me welcome
our second distinguished guests sorry
Elizabeth I was wondering it's almost
your turn our second distinguish guest
Elizabeth Alexander is a poet essayist
playwright and the Thomas E Donnelly
professor of african-american studies at
Yale she currently chairs the African
American Studies department here at Yale
she's published two collections of s
eight essays libretti for musical
projects and six books of poems
including American sublime which was one
of three finalists for the Pulitzer
Prize in 2009 Elizabeth composed and
delivered praise song for the day at the
first inauguration of President Barack
Obama a poem that was simultaneously
translated as canto de alabanza para el
dia on that day Elizabeth urged all of
us to quote say it plain that many have
I'd for this day sing the names of the
dead who brought us here who laid the
train tracks raised the bridges picked
the cotton and the lettuce built brick
by brick the glittering edifices they
would then keep clean and work inside of
widely anthologized Elizabeth
Alexander's work has been translated
into many languages including Spanish
German Italian Arabic and Bengali she
was one of the first recipients of the
Alphonse Fletcher senior fellowship for
work that quote contributes to improving
race relations in American society and
furthers the broad social goals of the
US Supreme Court's brown v board of
education decision of 1954 in 2007
Elizabeth Alexander was awarded the
first Jackson prize for poetry and she
was recently named Ann Annis field wolf
book award winner for her lifetime
achievement in poetry now in January of
2009 we had the opportunity to host a
discussion with Elizabeth Alexander
immediately after her reading of the
inaugural poet poem at the first
inauguration and were thrilled to have
her back and to provide this stage for
Richard Blancos first post inauguration
public appearance this year so far as we
know this event marks the first time in
which to inaugural poets have shared a
stage together and I want to thank our
sponsors for making this happen Ezra
Stiles college the office of the
president at Yale University the African
American Studies department the
ethnicity race and migration program la
casa de doll at Yale the university's
Office of Public Affairs and blue flower
arts Richard Blanco has agreed today to
read for about 15 minutes Elizabeth
Alexandra will then share her own
thoughts and ask Richard some questions
and after that we'll open up the floor
to audience questions for some 15 or 20
minutes so please join me in welcoming
inaugural poets Richard Blanco and
Elizabeth
thank you okay I apologize for my
eagerness but it felt like it felt like
that day on the platform I was like come
on Kelly hurry up okay I want to get
this over with already it's it's an
honor and a pleasure and a delight to be
here when Elizabeth first approached me
with this idea i just thought was
phenomenal and like like her master pity
said the first time in history where we
actually get to have a conversation
between these experiences I'm really
excited about what questions and answers
you might have more than my own reading
but I'm hoping we can also maybe get to
the bottom of the Beyonce thing tonight
as I was there okay I know the truth
anyway I've picked a few poems just
three poems and then the inaugural poem
through problems that I think are in
some ways ancestors to the inaugural
poem and one of those I was what master
PT mentioned was the first the first
poem I ever wrote not ever the first one
I wrote in a Creative Writing course my
first creative writing course with
Campbell McGrath and the very first
assignment in class was write a poem
about America so I'm going like all
Americans and I'm like thinking what
daffodils like and it really was almost
all most faked that that that very first
poem started me writing on that theme of
culture identity cultural negotiation
are really asking what is America in my
context so one could say I've been
writing about American along for a long
long time though that didn't make the
inaugural poem much easier to write but
nonetheless that's sort of the
background I felt a little more
comfortable I think on that so you
should know three things for this poem
and it's a it's a humorous poem of
someone but for Cubans a pork is not the
other white meat it's the only meat
what was the other thing oh we never
really got Thanksgiving we call it son
giving like signing nausea or sign paler
or the other son giving and also I think
if the White House had ever read this
line in here about Kennedy I may not be
here today I would may have been here
tonight as that quoting me I've just
that's what I heard so anyway and the
poem is called America or America
although Thea medium boasted she
discovered at least half a dozen uses
for peanut butter topping for guava
shells and syrup butter substitute for
Cuban toast hair conditioner and relax
her my mom never knew what to make of
the monthly five pound jars handed out
by the Immigration Department until my
friend Jeff mentioned jelly there was
always pork though for every birthday
and wedding whole ones on Christmas and
years eve even on Thanksgiving Day pork
fried broiled or crispy skin roasted as
well as cauldrons of black beans fried
plantain chips and you Coco mojito these
items required a special visit to
Antonio's Mikado on the corner of eighth
Street where men and why aveda's stood
in Senate blaming Kennedy for everything
ese hijo de puta the but the bile of
Cuban coffee and cigar residue Creasy
filling the creases of their wrinkled
lips clinging to one another's lives of
lost wealth ashamed and empty as hollow
trees by seven I had grown suspicious we
were still here overheard conversations
about returning had grown wistful and
less frequent I spoke English my parents
didn't we didn't live in a two-story
house with a maid or wood panel station
wagon narvik a shin camping in Colorado
none of the girls had hair of gold none
of my brothers or cousins were named
Greg Peter or Marsha we were not the
Brady Bunch none of the black and white
characters on Donna Reed or the Dick Van
Dyke Show were named guadalupe lado
mercedes petty dukes family wasn't like
us either they
have pork on Thanksgiving they ate
turkey with cranberry sauce they didn't
have you got they had yams like the
dittos of pilgrims I colored in class a
week before Thanksgiving I explained to
my way leta about the Indians and the
Mayflower how Lincoln set the slaves
free I explained to my parents about the
purple mountains majesty one if by land
two if by sea the cherry tree the tea
party the amber waves of grain the
masses yearning to be free liberty and
justice for all until finally they
agreed this Thanksgiving we would have
Turkey as well as pork I would lead to
prepared the poor foul as is committing
an act of treason faking her enthusiasm
for my sake mama said a frozen pumpkin
pie in the oven and prepared candied
yams following instructions I translated
from the marshmallow bag the table was
arrayed with gladiolas the platter
turkey loomed at the center on plastic
silver from Woolworths everyone sat in
green velvet chairs we had a fostered
with clear vinyl except do catalyst and
dhoti seated in the folding chairs from
the Salvation Army I uttered a bilingual
blessing and the turkey was passed
around like a game of russian relay dry
deal bread to complain and proceeded to
drown the lean slices with pork fat
drippings and cranberry jelly a
semi-arid aroha as he called faces fell
when mama presented her ochre pie
pumpkin was a home remedy for ulcers not
a dessert di Maria made three rounds of
Cuban coffee then away low and paper
cleared the living room furniture put on
a silly accrues LP and the entire family
began to madinah over the linoleum of
our apartment sweating rum and coffee
until they remembered it was nineteen
seventy and forty six degrees in America
after repositioning the furniture an
appropriate darkness filled the room the
oberto was the last one to leave
if you remember the inaugural poem there
were two very distinct autobiographical
moments our references one was to my
mother one was to my father and I
thought for today I give you a little
sort of a sneak peek behind the curtains
or let you know them a little bit better
by reading a poem one of them each which
or as as an immigrant exile family from
an immigrant exile family family life is
front and center in many of my poems
this one particularly about my mother
whom I revere for several reasons and I
met odds for several reasons as well but
something the courage I can't I keep on
fathoming the courage it takes and this
is one of the inaugural poems I worked
on over the three there had to write but
the courage it took to leave everything
you know every single cousin your parent
every single brother every single sister
every single cousin nice aunt nephew
every playground he ever played in every
street you ever knew and hop on a plane
and turn around and say goodbye never
really knowing that at that time that if
you were ever going to be able to come
back and offer the sake of one love for
my father to fought him following my
father but also for a better life which
is the immigrant story of course for my
brother and I and something my brother
in life just constantly just whenever we
get really mad at her we think about
these moment that moment and that
incredible courage and this is a
portrait of her sort of a more recent
portrait or for where I think she's
reached a really wonderful space in her
life after all that suffering and loss
Venus in Miami Beach what calls her to
the sea she rises steps towards the
shore with the temperament of a bride
her shadow a long train pulled across
the sand behind her parting a flock of
seagulls screeching away into the wind
her swollen ankles and frail shoulders
disappear inch by inch under her body
as she wades into the water becoming as
young as i remember her in a photo
posing like a mermaid for my father once
as gorgeous as her name haisa once a
girl chasing fireflies who hadn't lost
her home and country sisters and husband
once a mother who watched me as i watch
her now afraid of her alone with the sea
i waved to her but she turns away from
me fixes her eyes on the horizon and
beyond I'd nothing I can see needing no
one it seems like Venus's gaze I'm
tempted to think born full-grown out of
the sea but today she's not a goddess or
a girl not even my mother but simply a
her floating in the circle of her own
arms a water lily tranquil and sure of
her being being and this last portrait
before we get to the inaugural is of my
father but really about my father's more
of my father's relationship which is
somewhat typical for the Latino
generation of that time very silent
relationship I think the ministration
forgot another first which was the first
engineer to read oh
I should have reminded them about that
so this poem also gives you a little bit
of sort of a little peek at my
engineering side and my career as an
engineer which I think will not be
happening from now so finally I had God
chose for me so um anyway it's called
Papa's bridge morning driving west again
away from the Sun rising in the suit in
the slit of the rearview mirror as I
climb on slabs of concrete and steel
bent into a bridge aching with all its
parabolic y squared splendor I rise to
meet the shimmering faces of buildings
above treetops meshed into a calico of
greens forgetting the river below runs
insists on running and scouring the
earth moving at grain by grain and for a
few inclined seconds every morning I'm
12 years old again with my father
standing on the 10th floor window of his
hospital room gazing at the same bridge
like a mammoth bone aching with the
gravity of its own demps wait the glass
dosed by a tepid light reviving the city
as I watched and read his sleeping
wondering if he could even dream in such
dreamless white was he falling was he
flying was he falling was he flying who
was he who was I underneath his eyelids
flitting like the birds across rooftops
and early morning stars wasting away the
rush hour cars pushing through the
avenues like the tiny blood cells
through his vein the IV spiraling down
like a string of clear licorice feeding
his forearm bruised pearl and lavender
colors of the more
Hayes and the pills on his tongue the
stitches healed while the room kept
sterile with the usual silence between
us three days i served in water or juice
and wilting paper cups flipped through
muted soap operas and game shows filled
out filled out menu card stamped bland
diet for three nights i wedged flat
strange pillows around his bed his body
shaped like a fallen s and morderd in
place by layers of stiff percale when he
was ordered to walk I took his hand
together we stepped to the window and he
spoke you'll know how to build bridges
like that someday today I cross this
city this bridge still spanning the
silent distance between us with the
memory of a father and son holding hands
and secretly in love and now for st.
auger which I've been asked in a lot of
interviews how did you I don't know if
it Elizabeth had one I don't want to
preempt our conversation but I've been
asked like how did you get up there with
all those people you know and actually
you don't really see it in your face
when yeah so actually this is this is
actually much more welcoming and
intimate but it's also much but here
also some sort of much more exposed but
I did want to say I don't I want to
leave some things for questioning the
answer but they want to say a couple
things and one was in order if you've
picked up this already from reading the
poem but parts of the inspirations or
the genesis of the poem and of course
and went back to Maya and Elizabeth's
poem and i liked the shorthand that you
kind of need to write this poem which
was sort of relying on symbols of nature
and sort of took that i think from my as
i look back in retrospective course and
from elizabeth elizabeth poem that
catalog of people is just something soda
lye
full and I'd like I wanted to work with
that and I also realized i was just
happen with Elizabeth a it's not just
you writing that poem there there's
almost there has to be some kind of
continuity that you're looking at almost
like a sub-genre of the poetry because
it's something none of us if you know we
get to ask so few of us get asked to do
and it's not something you do in the
course of a poet all time this sort of
celebration of America or some in that
context so I feel like there's there's
also a lineage of something that you
have to pay homage to and so I hope I
wanted to say that it to this group
because I thought it was very important
that that you know that and also I also
holding on to i think that the sort of
spiritual genesis of the poem was
certain fundamental beliefs that I've
always Lord of Hell for a long time and
I think that comes from a tight-knit
exile immigrant community and that's the
idea of the importance of the individual
within that community and what they
contribute to it and how it takes
everyone in that community to make it
work and when you think that as just
sort of think I took that to a larger
degree and looking at our country and
our quality of life and how everyone is
interconnected not just spiritually in
this in the zenoss in the zen-like way
but also in a very practical manner as
well how we all need to work together in
many ways to make everything work and
the respect that I think is due and
something that was instilled in me
perhaps by my mother the respect that is
due to each and every one of us no
matter what walk of life you come from
no matter what's going on the idea of
you know yes it's hard economic times
but you know respect is respect and
honor no matter what where we're at so
anyway those were some of the things of
course this I look back in retrospect
and and see where it's where some of
these things came from in the creative
process is so much subconscious stuff is
going on so I'll read this and then we
can get on to the conversation
that's right oh great yeah this is
getting long poems no thanks to one
today one Sun rose on us today kindled
over our shores peeking over the Smokies
greeting the faces of the Great Lakes
spreading a simple truth across the
Great Plains than charging across the
Rockies one light waking up rooftops
under each one a story told by silent
gestures moving behind windows my face
your face millions of faces and mornings
mirrors each one yawning to life
crescendoing into our day pencil yellow
school buses the rhythm of traffic
lights fruit stands apples limes and
oranges arrayed like rainbows begging
our praise silver trucks heavy with oil
or paper bricks or milk teaming over
highways alongside us on our way to
clean tables read Ledger's or save lives
to teach geometry or ring up groceries
as my mother did for 20 years so I could
write this poem for us today all of us
as vital as the one light we move
through the same light on blackboards
with lessons for the day equations to
solve history to question or atoms
imagined the I have a dream we keep
dreaming or the impossible vocabulary of
sorrow that won't explain the empty
desks of 20 children marked absent today
and forever
many prayers put one light breathing
color into stained glass windows life
into the faces of bronze statues warmth
onto the steps of our museums and park
benches as mothers watch children slide
into the day one ground our ground
rooting us to every stalk of corn every
head of wheats owned by sweat and hands
hands gleaning coal or planting
windmills and desert sand hill tops that
keep us warm hands digging trenches
routing pipes and cables hands as worn
as my father's cutting sugar cane so my
brother and I could have books and shoes
the dust of our farms and deserts cities
and planes mingled by one wind or breath
breathe hear it through the days
gorgeous din of honking cabs buses
launching down avenues the symphony of
footsteps guitars and screeching
Subway's the unexpected songbird on your
clothes line here squeaky playground
swings trains whistling or whispers
across cafe tables here the doors we
open for each other all day saying hello
Shalom Buon Giorno howdy namaste or
buenos dias in the language my mother
taught me in every language spoken in 21
wind carrying our lives without
prejudice as these words break from my
lips one sky since the Appalachians and
Sierra's claim their majesty and the
Mississippi and Colorado worked their
way to the sea thank the work of our
hands weaving steel into bridges
finishing one more report for the boss
and time stitching another wound or you
form the first breast stroke on a
portrait or the last floor on the
Freedom Tower jutting into a sky that
yields to our resilience one sky toward
which we sometimes lift our eyes tired
from work some days guessing at the
weather of our lives some days giving
thanks for love that loves you back
sometimes praising a mother on you how
to give or forgiving a father who
couldn't give what you wanted we head
home through the glass of rain or weight
of snow or the plum blush of dusk but
always always home always under one sky
our sky and always one moon like a
silent drum tapping on every rooftop and
every window of one country all of us
facing the Stars hope a new
constellation waiting for us to map it
waiting for us to name it together
okay namaste thank you thank you let's
good driver that was so beautiful and
you know you talked about this but I
want to know how that felt because going
into your reading you talked about and I
think we saw one of the great
accomplishments of the poem is that it
was on the grand scale I mean it was you
know it was a big poem as was called for
it had a sweeping grandeur but it was
incredibly intimate and you know I
remember thinking oh I can never the
poem was built for that it wasn't built
for this but actually it just becomes
something else yeah when it's in
different spaces so I just wonder how it
felt to read it here oh actually it felt
actually much more connected actually
with an audience because I was saying
before their third you you see the sea
of people and and you're not sure you
know what's going on I mean you feel
intimate on the platform and one of my
moments was when I was walking back and
actually James Taylor technion the
shoulders and nice I can die now what
what what what I did feel intimately I
mean this is obviously you know a much
more sort face-to-face connection that
makes the poem even more alive for me at
this point you know in sight still you
get off that podium and you're not sure
how it went over exactly right and you
never know and yeah it's like it's it's
you know you get feedback later and
things like that but at that moment
you're not sure exactly how how it kind
of goes and and I was just remember
turning to my mother and just saying
well mom I think we're finally American
and one of the sweet things and I think
I've mentioned this is that as I went up
to the podium both president vice
president stood up to greet me which I
wasn't expecting a nose that's the the
protocol or whatnot so that gave me like
an extra sort of sense of welcomed I
like almost like here read
which was which I think gave me a lot of
courage but i but I tell you I it was
what I don't know if that was your
experience with you we had also had a
sound check so I was used to that view
but you don't have you know I don't see
the faces so in a way the more intimate
things are the more you're exposed right
so I felt a little less exposed actually
if you think about it with 800 thoughts
of people can I do right now well it's
it's very very beautiful and I'm glad
also that you read poems that you think
of his ancestors because I wanted to
know if you thought of this poem is
something kind of out of your body of
work or if it feels like a you know
brother or a distant relation to two
years other worlds well one of the big
learning experiences and one of one of
the really big hurdles i had in writing
the poem was as you read saw with my
mother and father from I'm used to
running about very sort of familiar in
intimate subjects and and I kept on
thinking well I know it can't be that
poem but how do you apply your same
voice to to this poem and and all that
while I thought my poetry was was was
received because of what I wrote about
and then I started looking at is no it's
what you how you write about what you're
writing about and once that clicked I
said I'll just try to apply that same
sort of dense imagery and intimate voice
to some other subject matter and that
was a big leap and it's answered
question further I think it opened up
something that I was very scared to do
yeah I've been asking all these
questions about America but always serve
in the confines of my immediate serve
ethnic exiled community experience and
now it gave me courage to sort of
exploreamerica in another way that I
hadn't seen so I could see it almost as
a beginning it's still a little bit more
of like a cousin right now as you saw
compared to the others but I'm excited
about going out in writing or about
America in different ways that I hadn't
thought about before and doing this pro
gave me the assignment the opportunity
and the courage so that's wonderful
because I think yeah there's something
about it's the movement in your palm
and the way they start in very very
intimate spaces I was so I loved reading
that you cleared out your work space to
write this poem and you wrote it at the
kitchen table yeah we're all thought
about that actually that's where you do
it you know i mean that's where life is
and that's where I feel like if there is
a place in your poems metaphorically you
know what emanates from the kitchen
table is is kind of where you are but
then from that intimacy we move out but
you know but very gracefully very
quietly so I think that actually you you
made movement that seemed familiar to me
from other poems and it's a great
strength like um so our mutual dear
friend Campbell McGrath your teacher my
high school classmate all right um okay
yeah we went we're in the same high
school less isn't that crazy and he so
he's the first person who told me about
about your work he was always has been a
very very proud teacher yeah um and so I
loved and I think it perhaps it was that
America poem where you know the first
poem you wrote in his class went right
into your first it's a first poem in the
first book and yeah and he said it just
came out and there it wasn't there you
were and you were doing what you were
supposed to be doing but he also said as
you know that he thinks that he you
brought your engineer brain that there
was something about structure that you
understood very intrinsically that that
was manifest in the poems could you say
more about that well I I think it it
happens this way I think it works for
and against me at times but when I'm in
pure creative mode I have to let go of
that a little bit you know to just let
words come in images and not have the
idea that I have to structure it or
whatnot and then once I get sort of some
raw material on paper or something
that's closer to a draft then where the
engineer comes in is as the editor and
starts looking at sort of logic and
patterns and language and how things are
connected and because he's already said
I just become this ruthless editor at
that point I'm just like okay the bridge
can't be this way it's going to fall
apart and so it gives me that detachment
when the left brain kicks in and it's
just sort of looking at it almost from a
more analytical point of view
by the same token sometimes I overdo
that and so if you'll notice any of my
poems just aesthetically of visually on
the page I don't like that all the line
breaks have to be kind of about the same
length if I write a 1 @n line stands in
the next line is nine lies them like
yeah we gotta get I really like really
makes me uncomfortable because I like
patterns I like you know as algorithms
you know things that they can can rep
replicated sort of have this even this
visual dimension to them so so that's
where the the engineer comes in and I've
always thought all my life I need to do
both in some ways you know at some point
during the process of writing the poem
and I had to like do a spreadsheet I had
to do something and I let it go she'll
let the other side of the brain rest and
then come back in and not look at it you
know it's like so I kind of have to like
in full entertain one and make him go
away while this was and then I got it
like this one girl while the other one
works Wow but it's it's it's the way I
was wired I mean my dad obviously
influenced me to study engineering but I
was very good at math and it was kind of
a be a be student and most things which
made it hard to decide and at first I
thought I was I thought it was a sort of
a negative mark on me that I was an
engineer and then I realized this like
most people are asking me oh you're an
engineer does I feel like this could be
a compliment edge yeah and I think also
I mean there are always these kind of
sub rosa ways of organizing that you
know you can articulate it but it also
is at work in a way that is I mean we
want these poems to hold together
although I think also what's really nice
is that in most of your poems there's a
moment of break or not resolution in the
poems that you read that the endings do
not resolve and I think that also that
moment in the middle of the inaugural
poem where you say breathe and where you
stop and you give us all that moment
which actually I appreciate it because I
was sitting there watching you not
breathing
no watching like her sister or something
and then soon okay fine everything is
fine um but I think that that's actually
something that is a wonderful counter to
to all of that nice wire yeah yeah I
gotta and those are the moments that
have to remember to like you know the
engineer wants to resolve everything and
sort of tie everything up nice and
neatly and sometimes I that's where I
have to come back somewhere in the
middle and say okay you know leave it
you know there's you know more in
between the lines than there are in the
lines sometimes and I wonder also about
we were talking a little bit in the
kitchen about Spanish and I was trying
to think about I've decided I don't like
the word Spanglish as a way of sort of
describing what it means to have more
than one language to call upon what that
incredibly complex mixture of having all
of it at your disposal is all about you
know that there are things that can be
done in Spanish that can't be done in
English and vice versa and so I want to
call that you could talk some about that
and about how that affects your poetics
well I've and most of my books are at
least one or two examples of where i'll
i'll write a poem that either topically
i feel i need to translate into spanish
and also poems that i right first come
to me in spanish and i translate into
English and and this is only something
you can do with your own work but i
think you were saying things that don't
work and then there are different modes
of thinking because it's another
language so when it doesn't work on one
language i'll go back to the original
language and and sort of see if what i
came up when the spanish will work in
the english and then I changed the
English and then it works in the Spanish
and so the poem looks like a literal
translation but really they were worked
out together and and I find that that
that's helps the poem because it it
breathes something else into the poem
from another language it makes me think
of another way or just sounds and things
like that we're working with the
translator now officially for the other
two poems and I had to write and I'm
finding out from this translating world
that gerunds in
in Spanish are like taboo ugly nobody
like nobody likes him and I'm like a
chair and freaky yeah so I've had the
battle or those like that doesn't sound
right to me like she's like saying and
it made me understand and then I
actually went back a little bit and
teased with some of those okay maybe
maybe if this was in a present tense it
would actually work like the does in
Spanish it gives you access to sort of
almost workshop your own home and
another thing and sometimes I'll think
how does this line sometimes just out of
the blue all this this line sound in
Spanish and I'll say it to myself in
Spanish and I was like yeah that looks
nice and let me do that in English yeah
I think also there are the people that
you bring in with Spanish in the poems
and you've talked about you know those
family members who are getting older and
how that became an impetus for some
aspects of your poetry and how you
wanted them to it was a beautiful thing
that you said that you you want to make
them live forever on paper as you
yourself want to live forever on paper
and I think that you know you're not a
nostalgia stem but you are trying to
capture something that is that is
fleeting and precious and in the
language it seems to me that that's one
way that you could do that because you
couldn't have translated that uncle's
line about candy and yeah I would have
around what or yeah yeah there's Peter
come in there yeah there's pieces of
them in there and and and that's a
something I get from Campbell actually
lies is that sense of being as the poet
as a historian in a way an emotional
historian and a lot of the the the the
inspiration for the first book was to
sort of record emotionally who this
first the the sort of yearnings and
contradictions and things like this
first Cuban American generation went
through because they were going to be
gone there's only one first bridge
generation you know and and so that's
always remained with me and
in that aspect of recording recording
emotions as almost like a historian as a
historical document and that's what I
actually love about wish it was law that
they had to write an inaugural Pullman
every at every inauguration because it
takes a snapshot emotionally of where
the country is in each at least every
four years and some some years it's been
too far into between that but I love how
you know you can take Roberts for also
see where the country was there then you
know your poem and see where we were
there hopefully you know there'll be
others and it's almost like I said like
a sub-genre these snapshots so I I try
it I a lot of my inspiration is is is
that recording of that emotional history
and paying tribute to those our
ancestors people that come before us and
like it says in there I'm here because
of these people was one of the first
things when I heard the news after I
called a few people to make sure they
weren't playing a practical joke on man
I had to pull over and sit on the side
of the road and basically weep and then
the first people I thought about where
my grandparents my parents and I took a
photo with me the only thing I took in
that binder was a photo of painted
photograph of my great grandparents whom
I've never met obviously and that they
were there or to me oh that's that's
what sort of reading too and you were
with your mom and what's my mom of
course yeah I was with my dad and oh
yeah yeah and my my husband had said he
goes up there because the world needs to
see the white hair know and really in a
very profound way you know that it's not
just about who our generation is in the
present it's a it's about the elders and
it's about how we got there and so I
think it's so beautiful my partner
actually insisted that my mother go to
yeah it was a great act of love to Italy
just think that that that sense to of
like you know that's the most
appropriate person at that moment yep
yep yep and then what about you know so
many identities we have
and accept the youngest we have to
change that because I was I need to like
be over hey yeah let it be said yeah um
but um but you're a Florida poet too um
and I think that your poetry you know I
think about Elizabeth bishops you know
the state with a prettiest name upload
in brackish water and you know
Campbell's Florida poems and and and you
know just all of the Florida poems and
your Florida poem talking to those can
you talk some about that or maybe it's
not even Florida it's Miami er um it's
it's mostly it's mostly Miami and it's
something that I've I think in the third
book I have to I'm starting to deal with
a lot again in that sense of home and of
place and identity which obsesses me and
miami the miami i grew up in it's
certainly not the miami of today and I
have it's almost like I say it's like my
Cuba it's like yeah I go there and I'm
lost and I go to the restaurant it's a
condo building I go somewhere else at
some fancy shmancy the other and I feel
like I've been erased from the landscape
or my memory has been here and I feel
like the way my parents go well my
mother would good go to Cuba and they
start complaining about how did how dare
they change the name of that street and
why I think this kind of stuff and I
finally suffer the same nostalgic sort
of like apprehension and rant about and
that's we're looking for the Gulf motel
came from is any went back to Marco
Island after 20 years I'm like what's
going on here and so uh yeah it's all in
that makes it because there's there's
home is a state of mind but it's also a
physical environment it's also the
things the streets we walk through the
you know the stores we go into and two
parallel that with my engineering one of
the things that I specialize in is
called urban Urban Redevelopment or
streetscaping or village of finding
things where we went into certain places
in Miami and just basically redid a
makeover over the town to make it more
walkable bring them up to date and I
have one poem about that that I read in
my hard hat once
the groundbreaking ceremony but it was
it occurred to me i am changing the
landscape that i'm complaining about you
know that people are changing like you
know the you know the people they know
this street for what it is they're gonna
be like what they do that for so I feel
attachment to place and that's why I
travel a lot and and and have lived in
different places is trying to find that
connection not just spiritually and
emotionally amendment but but that the
actual landscape that influences is so
much and how we feel are the
architecture all the other arts that's
Orion's around is amazing and community
and now i'm in bethel me go figure um
well there are many questions for you
here but I have one more I must ask I
have many more cheese may be on same I
need to know everything I need to know
like you know how is she ten feet tall
how tall was her hair off her head she
was a wig I want to know everything so
she was she was pretty shows about my
height so that's pretty tall for female
right and I thought I i first tried to
sneak in to see her with with my friend
Nikki and her people or like no you
can't so then so you mean in the cap she
was in the capital yeah Dre old during
the hounds the sound check ah and after
that um all I remember was seeing her
chandan ear thing which was like an IV
actually and then and then you as you
know if they're you can't really hear
too much when you're up there cuz it's
all meant to project that way and um so
I was just like I don't know the story
exactly but afterwards um she liked the
poem and she she asked for an appearance
you know for an audience for me wow so I
want to see her and and she was just
like she was a nervous wreck like me
like she was we were talking about even
Kelly Carson when she came back from the
aisle she's like oh my god that was so
nerve-racking and that's when I said if
they're nerve-racked I can do this this
is normal to be nervous
act at this point and she seemed very
nice and natural and that i found the
gossip later and all this stuff and then
I think someone quoted me as saying I
didn't lip sync my home like they were
at it was a it was a loaded question it
wasn't any of you said would you have
licked lip sync to your poem if he could
ever like what's this guy asked I
answered very earnestly well you can't
really because you know hey all he
wanted me to say it was like I wouldn't
live sync but but she's she seemed she
seemed very genuine and sweet and what
was so surprising was that she was
nervous like on all of us and what was
even more I don't know if Elizabeth you
got to sense up there you know all the
while I haven't never been quite a
patriotic person but I've always held
America up to those beliefs that I
always that I learned in grade school
somewhere in the back of my mind there
was always those ideals when I was
sitting on that platform at least for
those two hours and I don't know if this
is because I'm a poet or was still in my
poem there there was that fundamental
that those fundamental ideas for those
two hours still held it was like we
can't and you know why we get jaded and
we think and all the things that are
going on and for those two hours Beyonce
and me and James Taylor and all the rest
are here force one purpose for one
purpose only and they felt that honor
and you feel that that for those two
hours one today I mean it really felt
that energy and I never embraced America
fully until that moment and I realized
that those very ideals that I thought
were just things in picture books and
you know fancy words they're still there
somehow and it was like it brought tears
to my eyes I was like they're still
there we haven't been able to erase that
no matter what you know it looks like a
media or what it looks like and it was
such an amazing experience when i turn
my mind I think I'm finally American
okay I finally embraced something that I
hadn't embraced at some point yeah I
thought about that um
in real I felt that it was rather a
small platform know the entire
government yeah sure intimate and oh
yeah I mean so that that you know
everyone is there and of course in the
case of the first one power was being
transferred yeah which is even more and
it was happening peacefully and it would
happen and it did happen and that
everyone was there to bear witness and
everyone was there in some kind of
collectivity and being in the crowd this
time i also anna kept saying oh it's so
different oh so relaxed but I looked I
looked back at all the people from the
ground and thought you know oh this is
what common ground means ya know this is
what it means that all of these people
have chosen and together as far as the
eye can see you know for common purpose
despite all of differences and it's it
is amazing it it's just like it's like
an ideal brought to life in that very
experienced that was I was amazing yet
with you I can I mean that was the real
transfer of power that must have been
like even more even more present it was
yeah you know it was it was and it was
not quite totally believable because
there was all of the you know people
didn't think it would happen in their
lifetime yeah you know so so there was
that real I i I'm not sure people
thought it would actually happen right
back him Sookie really I mean I felt on
the stage an exhale a collective
exhalation and there were a lot of
elders on that stage when it finally
happened and it was finally true and
that was so amazing I mean it's amazing
experiencing and I'm such a fan I want
to go to every nogger a Chanel to Yahweh
to take that breather you know to take
that moment say let's pause and yeah and
do this and and support that idea you
know that we do this then it's not a
joke it's not yeah there's a lot of
fluff in it but it's not it's not i mean
it is not just pomp and circumstance
here if you read the oath i don't know i
went back and read the oath i mean those
words are very significant yeah it's
like that i come here without that under
duress and all this other stuff
amazingly anyway now I'm like I don't
want to run for office well you are now
you are now the investor poetry and so I
think I know I said that was the last
question but I just want to say that I
was so proud of you and I think that you
know there was a way that American poets
were with you because you represented us
right that's another piece you got to be
there and we're not there a lot though
we do what we do and so I wondered how
you feel you know as a poet amongst
others um I think it's something I've
always craved in the sense of I consider
my work very accessible and and and i
think i right or my subject matters have
always been sort of salt of the earth
people and and I've always sort of
struggled with you know I want the the
people in my poems to be the ones
reading my poems as well while yet
maintaining you know certain aesthetic
and crafts quality of craft and whatnot
and sometimes that's hard to do and so
that connection with such a large
diverse audience and and what happened
afterward in the city was amazing I was
more amazing than the actual event it
was like I'll never forget this doorman
at a hotel that it was meeting somewhere
nowhere he just looked at me and took my
hands and give me some love he just
hugged me into they asked me who it just
recognizing and this little asian
american lady who came out i don't know
where she came out of an alley I don't
know where she she just popped out
barely spoke English I'm sure she had a
little autographed book and she wanted
me to sign she gave me this big hog and
like I mean if poetry can do that let's
do the least I said let's make this law
yeah and the other piece that had been
main magazine had recently asked me to
publish upon all about seven months ago
and then the editor like he's that took
out the poetry page
and now they're putting the portrait and
they wrote me and the editor said you
know thank you for saving poetry again
and you know because of the exposure
that that brings to to everyone else and
and and to feel that poetry can connect
in the ways that we always hope but we
don't get those audiences or those
opportunities once it maybe not even
once an eye for us maybe once in a
lifetime but it's difficult you know
it's it's hardly as your your your heart
is so much in everything around you and
sometimes poetry can be such a you know
closeted art you know well others have
questions I oh you want to draw traitor
I'm horrible at it yea big so I'm I'm
curious how you chose to balance
particular and universal images in the
in the inaugural Tom and that you spoke
Lola dots or the particular experience
your big experience mr. general American
experience and I'm curious more about
sort of the lake like damages of 11 moon
one light one land could be could be
interpreted as more and more Universal
than just like one American right I had
one American light so so how did you
decide or how I guess how did you turn
those possibly universal symbols into
American symbols and how did you decide
to do that part of it is I maybe I
didn't say well enough though part of it
that is you need some kind of shorthand
right is that or something some kind of
glue that serve bonds these catalogues
of images together for me and I took I
took a cue from from Maya's poem with
the rock the tree the river and so I
thought that nature is such a powerful
sort of encompass any the glue both both
as an image in the sense that we all
look at one son we all look at one moon
we all breathe one air figuratively and
then to counterbalance that I thought I
need some very specific moments of
imagery and then to counter to counter
that I'd say I always had to feel like I
needed to put a little
of my own autobiographical piece in
there which was very scary to do and I
had a lot more than I took out and that
was that was kind of how I mapped it I
had wanted to my captain a focus on this
theme of you know this idea as I said
that the belief that I've held is like
how we all work have to work together
for very practical and spiritual reasons
but I couldn't find that one thing to
put it to the constant reference point
and then it became that those powerful
elements of nature that that are so
eternal and priority also about possible
vocabulary of sorrow you talk a little
bit about the decision to include
something it was very current
yeah that was happening while I was
reading the poem and as it as it was for
all of us such an amazing moment I still
get misty and it just felt completely
right to do that until to have that
recorded forever hopefully in this poem
I felt it was a moment that and there
have been of course other tragedies
where America comes together and and and
I felt well I didn't want to catalog too
many tragedies in the poem and I thought
if anything was most appropriate was
that moment which felt right in the way
because it happened while I was writing
the poem but also in the sense that i
also wanted a contemporary sense to the
poem in the in the sense that I there
were some problems when I started back
at the Pilgrims and dumb and it was like
a page is an effing and so because I was
so of the moment and because I think a
lot of the images you know I had to sort
of focus on okay in a sense i hear
america singing what does that sound
like today and and try to find some
boundary right because I mean it's the
the subject matters and the history Co
historical references and in my case
having to sort of the pressure feeling I
have to also makes particular references
to what I'm representing as a person
were overwhelming and so I had to find
some boundary to the poem but it just
felt just so right for me I had more
specific reference in it actually naming
the town I took that out because I
wanted some graduate student someday to
have to look at she mean by the 20 so i
put the 20 just to acknowledge it but
not be so obvious and I feel like
gratuitously including something for the
sake of you know just
of Valley no shock value or tear-jerking
Valley but rather it was really honestly
just wanting to have that recorded for
that moment and I went through the
emotional process while I was writing
the problem with all that I mean I was
like had to limit my viewing of it
actually as it was too much and I've
always worked go on for every stick a
Cuban up here I've worked a lot with
kids in about two weeks earlier i was in
Wilton Connecticut with an eighth-grade
class and they think that was part of
her teeth teaching them the Gulf motel
and there was just like eight periods of
8th graders which was had me a wreck by
the end of the day but they are so
amazing like the things that they were
getting from poetry and I think that was
also fresh in my mind that that
connection with the children figure see
so first of all we were so proud to have
you up there on the stage as he heard
they're about two hundred of us that
went to the inauguration it was great to
see you there my question is you've
mentioned that you have to write a
couple of other points I'm curious about
that and I'm also curious about the
process how do you get selected how does
that happen um did you I'm curious been
curious to ask Elizabeth they asked you
to write three as well they didn't um
and I think that it was yeah I know you
know what someone else might be the one
was enough I don't know how you did
three oh my god but I think also we were
speaking about this like no they nobody
knew what they were doing I mean you
know oh my god he just won the election
let's put on an inaugural it was very
put together yeah yeah yeah and I new
rule I think I think maybe because it
was such a short span if if I would
written upon that maybe they wouldn't
have light I thought maybe they wanted
to sort of stagger their bats and say
well they're between three but they
weren't so they weren't like you have to
write through they say we want three two
to three weeks i had four three poems so
um the right it it gives a new meaning
to the timed writing exercise but I was
glad I didn't tell me six months ago
because I would have done Hiram
you know I would have pulled on my hair
out and you know I mean six months
sitting on that so two weeks more would
have been a little better but the other
two poems are completely different
aspects of of what i did and i'm working
on them because i want to publish them
together as a trio as a triptych one is
very focused on my mother and it and it
allowed me to do the autobiographical
American experience poem through her
story and I needed to write that too and
I knew they weren't going to pick that
one but I wrote it and then the other
one is more of a metaphorical but using
one of things I've always felt about my
relationship with a country that it's
much like a romantic relationship you
know that there's the phase of the
innocence and your little kid and then
there's like you're like that's a time
like you're you know kind of going about
high school and worrying where you're
going to get a be here you know like and
then their eyes you know the shades part
open and you're like oh my god and then
you really look into history and you
would go through this rage period with
your country and you know the injustice
is and how could make I've done that and
you feel like the sense of betrayal when
you feel pick up start picking it
history a lot and then at some point you
also realize this sort of well so do
other kind of treats I mean that
nothing's perfect and that you've you
try work away and try to sort of work it
out and that often where you decide to
work with with a group of people or you
know you start being an activist or
something like that but it's that
dialogue that begins just like in a
relationship or like are we going to
give this up here or are we going to sit
around at the kitchen table and talk
this out because we need to talk and
that ends up and eventually a more long
lasting bond with your country that is
not the romantic sense of giving away
too much of it but I tried to trace that
in a poem that's sort of looking at
America's almost personifying America in
some way as a relationship of that we
have with love and
are so with loved ones and and and with
others other questions or comments
look at what then you uh I just want to
say how inspiring just your words in
this room have been today and uh if you
could say something or a small something
to aspiring poets in the room what would
you say to us I think I think what I
find missing in in air of Elizabeth
feels things up is to try to find
something you really care about and I
think that's really the secret to where
the writing enveloped and developed
something that obsesses you I know for
me before I wrote America I was writing
god-awful poems I mean it was I thought
I had to write like like you know
Wordsworth and you know I was writing
about daffodils that I didn't know what
looked like in Miami they don't have
definite but to find some of that really
is it you have something personally at
stake it and that's something you've
made up your mind about because if
you've made up your mind about something
there's nothing to explore in writing
but rather to approach something that
you feel you need to understand by
yourself and you need to understand it
for others and again that sense of
emotional historian that something
larger than yourself at the same time as
is as it's very intimate for me it was
you know Mike you an American generation
that I felt I needed to have have them
have a voice for me it's it's my family
and and and in some ways it's always
been about America you know in a
roundabout way that goes with all the
rest of take book you know you gotta go
to work shop you gotta do you got to put
your best foot forward you got to take
you know they're good with the bad the
feedback and all that but I think that's
a from here you got us in workshop it's
so easy to start here and get lost
appear in fact the the revision of the
one of the three poems ended up in God
in that god-awful wasteland of like this
benign like poem I workshop the magic
completely out of it
and it started all over again with the
original version and then merge them so
I mean that goes you know that goes
without saying but that sense of I think
that's the hardest thing that you can't
learn in a classroom is like that that
things look for that thing was with you
have any thoughts on that same question
advice to poets well what i would add on
to that thing is that not not everybody
is does or can it's actually a very very
sacred special thing each of us does
have our own sacred special thing it's
not poetry for everyone and so i think
that you know if it's yours it you know
tend it you know really really really
tended and part of what the tending it
means is continually reading and
understanding yourself as making poems
on a very long time line it also has
spokes that go all the way around the
world and so you know you're part of
poets across history and poets around
the globe and you're a dot in that in
that conversation and you have to know
what's in that conversation i think
that's really important time for one
final question if they're already yes
dirt um I a I didn't realize you an
engineer before and so I I really
appreciated that you both the you you
were an engineer and a poet and that you
bring the strengths from engineering
it's how you write poetry how I'm a
science major in over the summer I i
took an English course and had a really
great experience with my professor who
owned who we had a conversation when I
once about how the English department
really treats the English classes as for
English majors and that sometimes
frustrated with how it kind of overlooks
and makes it difficult for other majors
to be able to write and so do you have
give comments on this a little bit we
were saying about like I think what
we're missing sometimes is when one of
the things that I hope to maybe do from
now from on forward is that the
appreciation of poetry is something that
is also an art so there's a lot of focus
on writing port or becoming a poet but
the appreciation of poetry is something
that that also has its own art in the
way of teaching it and so that's why I
try to visit even from grade schools and
there's great teachers that know how to
put the poetry together and there's some
other or not but how do how do we how do
you do that in a classroom and not to
want to make a writer out of a little
Johnny you know but just appreciate
poetry there's a similar story as yours
which was a great experience I read at
the honors college and if I you almost
every year because it's my I got three
degrees from oh so this a science guy
okay i don't know i figured think it was
a biologist who was in the honors course
went on and got a science major he lasts
a few months ago he is teaching a tattle
paddle middle school he called me
because he remembered that like one
session with the poetry and he became a
fan of poetry and he was now bringing to
the creative writing Department a POI
that he liked because he reads poetry
and that's that that's a good point i
mean i think that we have to also i mean
i'm not teaching right now but there's
always there's there's a lot of creative
writing classes and i'm not sure we've
had that dialogue of how to how to teach
people are just to appreciate poetry in
the way that we appreciate painting or
music or another way so I something I
think that I don't have an answer to but
I think that's something I want I want
to work on it as we move forward as I
move forward and
sort of a cause if you would
thank you